if you are a pro-business Republican you
probably have at some point said that
corporations should be able to make the
decisions that are best for them except
of course when it is about people
protesting police brutality in which
case I guess the president should be
allowed to tell businesses that those
people should be suspended or that it is
him who wants to or it is he I guess I
would say who wants to be doing the
suspending and if that sounds confusing
to you it's because it is Donald Trump
tweeted that protesting NFL players who
don't stand for the national anthem
should be suspended without pay he said
quote the NFL players are added again
taking a knee when they should be
standing proudly for the national anthem
numerous players from different teams
wanted to show their outrage at
something that most of them are unable
to define they make a fortune doing what
they love be happy
be cool a football game that fans are
paying so much money to watch and enjoy
is no place to protest most of that
money goes to the players anyway find
another way to protest stand proudly for
your national anthem or be with capital
letters suspended without pay so what
I'm trying to understand here is whether
Trump is saying he's going to direct
teams to suspend players without pay or
is he saying he can suspend players
without pay who work not for him or the
government but for NFL teams what's he
actually saying here Trump tweets are
like poetry they're open to many
different interpretations and we can all
have different conclusions about him
unfortunately the law also has an
interpretation of what Donald Trump is
suggesting and what he's suggesting is
actually illegal 18 US Code subsection
227 called wrongfully influencing a
private entities employment decisions by
a member of Congress says that nobody
who is an agent of the government
whether it's Trump or a member of
Congress the executive branch whoever
can influence companies like the NFL to
take action like the suspension of
individual players and this has become a
completely partisan issue and it's
actually one of those partisan issues
that serves the powers
system that maintains the two-party
duopoly and I it's this is important
right if your philosophy underlying your
politics is that corporations should be
free to do what they want barring that
it's illegal and do what is best for
them then the President of the United
States should not be directing companies
or threatening to suspend people himself
but the the issue is here that this is
one of those distract a thon topics
right when Trump wants to take attention
away from the constant contradictions of
Rudy Giuliani his lawyer or from the
complete disaster that is going on in
the Paul Manafort trial or from whatever
this is one of those things that he can
go back to and I actually want want to
take it a step further because we've got
to be able to think and and walk at the
same time or chew gum and walk at the
same time statements are official acts
when the president makes a statement
it's an official act a tweet is a
statement okay so merely tweeting that
the NFL should suspend players without
pay when they kneel during the national
anthem that is all arguably illegal
however this is a really effective way
of riling people up and distracting them
the national anthem the Pledge of
Allegiance these are all distractions
NFL players are of course not government
employees Trump can't find them
he can't reprimand them but when you
talk about kneeling NFL players
particularly in early August when there
isn't even an NFL football season going
on yet this distracts from that Russia
meeting or the neo-nazis that
commemorated the one-year anniversary of
the Charlottesville rally or whatever
else this is something that makes it
really difficult for people because this
isn't nothing but it is a distraction
from really important issues yeah that's
exactly it is it's an distract the thon
especially because there's no real
update to this NFL kneeling controversy
story in every new season has started up
but it's not like the NFL has changed
its policy yeah so he's just making this
move to play to his base and it does
work for him it does and you know
kneeling in this way is speech Trump is
saying that there should be a punishment
for a particular type of speech
and he is the government doing it right
so that this really is a danger but it's
also important not to get so sucked in
that you forget about all the other
issues that Trump is actively
distracting and serving out
disinformation from